[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your question gimme two
V's advice and bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon hi
John how are you I'm all right you seem
a little sick I can tell even from your
voice that you're just not feeling a
hundred percent I'm not feeling a
hundred percent I have a sudden sudden
onset intestinal discomfort and now I'm
just I'm working my way through the
there's a bunch of pigeons that have
decided to live on my house and sure
they also seem to be in distress I like
this this times when you feel really
sick and you you just like end up saying
like hmm like you feel ya bad the
pigeons seem to be making that noise all
the time they're just outside of my
window either I don't know what's going
on like I don't know if that's just them
communicating with each other or what
but they do not seem happy and I'm just
thinking to myself well if you're not
happy here maybe go somewhere else poop
so I have recently come in possession of
several thousand pounds of wood chips
I'm covering my garden area with
woodchips and then putting some soil on
top of the wood it's called lasagna
gardening I don't want to get into it
too deeply but the nice thing about
being in possession of many thousands of
pounds of woodchips is that it requires
you to be outside moving those wood
chips with a pitchfork almost 24 hours a
day yeah and so how's your bones and
muscles and stuff bones are great
muscles not I'm fine until I stop
working and then as things start to
seize up pretty quickly but the point
here is that I have been afforded the
opportunity to do a great deal of
bird-watching in in the area around my
home and we have a lot of pigeons as
well we have an almost I would say an
infestation of pigeons there's some
chickadees
some beautiful doves you know that just
kind of hang out on the ground but then
there are these pigeons it's like the
Piazza San Marco or something there
they just descend and hang around and I
agree with you I'm a little bit over
pigeons now to me it's not it's not a
Canada geese level issue yet but I I'm a
little bit over pigeons Hank
do you have a short poem for us today
that's not how this works at all okay
well I don't
the pigeons at my window poop out many
eggs they make whole new generations oh
it's good to have little eight little
eggs
that's good that's very good that's very
good speaking of babies can I read you
our first question oh okay that's really
we're really just starting now we didn't
okay that was our poem I think our first
question comes from Amanda who writes
help three exclamation points I just
found three baby hamsters in my hamster
cage no I do I wasn't sure about the sex
of my hamsters but now I know for sure I
separated the parents but I'm not sure
what else to do I don't know anything
about baby hamster care any dubious
advice would be much appreciated not a
panda Amanda also I should add she sent
in this question two months ago so those
baby hamsters are now like middle aged
so well yeah we can we can definitely
not help which is great because I the
only information I have for you is that
pet stores will not take baby hamsters
is that true yeah no they won't they're
like nope we've we've had enough of
those I would suggest I was gonna
suggest that a man to get into the pet
store business to like see this as an
unexpected business opportunity I just I
don't think that there's like a shortage
of baby hamsters in the world uh without
what I think Amanda you now have three
new hamsters and usually that'll go okay
I guess you should put them with the
mother if you can tell which one that is
I assume that you can it's the one
that's nursing and just be like fingers
crossed and if doesn't go well then it
that's okay they were gonna die anyway
eventually boy Hanks in a great mood
well if I tell you what if you take your
so if you take your hamster to stick
your hamster's to the pet store they
might be like yeah we'll take them but I
can't guarantee where they're gonna end
up
oh good lord Hank okay move on how you
asked the question Amanda if I were you
I would turn to my favorite veterinary
advice podcast not necessarily my
favorite advice podcast about death
because I don't think we're gonna be
able to help with this one realistically
no I mean but but the good news is that
your hamsters are are well on to
wherever they were headed because it was
two months ago anyway this next question
comes from Jessica asks dear Hank and
John my roommate and I recently got into
a debate about how to tip our Pizza
deliverer I only had one dollar I only
had two $1 bills but we have a lot of
quarters I was always taught that it's
rude to tip people with change in
sit-down restaurants she argued that if
she were a delivery driver she would
rather have more money than less money
what Foreman said I'm pretty sure she's
right yeah this got me thinking there
are different tipping etiquettes for
different kinds of jobs also can i tip
my pizza delivery driver with my laundry
quarters advice of the dubious and non
dubious categories both are appreciated
John I think that even at a sit-down
restaurant you can give change right you
can't give just change so unjust change
well I what I will sometimes like I'll
get the money back and like I'll put 20
bucks in and then it'll come back with
like you know my $5.25 change and then
you know I'll just leave that and that's
okay yes that is acceptable I don't
think that you've ever been a restaurant
server and I have been once or I feel
moderately more qualified to answer this
question and when I was a server to
restaurant I wanted money and I did not
really care about the form of that money
like if you wanted to leave me a roll of
quarters that would be fine I did mind
is the money clean is it delivered to me
in a way that is designed to embarrass
or humiliate me for instance the person
who left me a $20 tip thank you but
covered
in the I would call it the nacho cheese
oh no but the restaurant that I worked
out I think we were not allowed to
technically call it cheese because it
didn't have any cheese in it so he
called it nacho cheese sauce but they
loved it covered in the nacho cheese
sauce and I was like it's such that's
why did why because now I have to clean
this $20 bill and go through this whole
rigmarole which is humiliating and I so
don't don't do that that's good advice
so if you're gonna give somebody six
dollars in quarters it's obviously not
an ideal way to get tipped as a delivery
driver so I might put it in a ziploc bag
or if you can roll the corners up so
it's a little bit easier for them to
deal with but it is way better to be
tipped six dollars in quarters and a two
and two one dollar bills than it is to
be tipped just to one dollar bills for
sure what you gotta do Jessa and I'm
just gonna throw this out here for
everybody load up that load up that let
that laundry straight with some second
to weigh us oh my god it's not trying to
make sacagawea's happen it already
happened the whole that's the whole
point John is that it already happened
so I mean like if the longview it like
you it may be that your laundry list
doesn't take seconds yet because they
aren't here with the rest of us in the
21st century but first of all talk to
them about that second it's works in the
parking meters in my town yeah so eggs
eggs advises to only tip in sacagawea's
to try to make secretary ways happen so
Hanks advice is to go to your local bank
yeah and instead of getting a hundred
dollars in 20s get a hundred dollars in
the form of 101 dollar coins and then a
hand those out like Ebenezer Scrooge
after his revelation oh that's money I
guess yes the sacagawea's person it's my
favorite person to deliver pizza to the
person who tips me at one dollar coins
this is like walking away loaded down
weighing five extra power
okay let's move on I think we've solved
this problem we're gonna move on to
Jessica's question who asks dear bug and
shrimp I'm very proud to be the advice
columnist of mycologist newspaper it's
really cool to see dear Jessica in print
every few weeks and I love feeling like
I'm able to help someone the problem is
that hardly anybody asks me questions as
people who have a successful
advice-giving platform do you have any
tips for how to get to ask questions
dear Yama Jessica the situation Jessica
is that like both with your advice
column and like every other advice
column that has ever gotten started from
scratch is you make it up you make them
up Jessica you make them up and that way
you can ask questions that you know how
to answer really nice you can you can
tailor it to your specific expertise or
something that happened to you that week
and be like well Melinda thank you for
writing in just this week I was trying
to figure out how to tip a pizza
delivery driver with my second - way up
right I mean do you think that was a
real problem that someone had Jessica of
course it wasn't we made it up because I
think Hank has made a solemn vow that he
is going to mention sacagawea's in every
podcast we make for the rest of our
lives and so he had to make it up yeah
yeah I feel bad that I that I've skipped
several weeks of not mentioning ants
Canada so ants Canada channel yeah I
mean I remember making up questions when
I first started making question Tuesday
videos like ten years ago we would get
some questions but sometimes we wouldn't
get the questions that I wanted to
answer and so I would find myself
thinking somebody would say oh what's
your favorite what's your favorite color
and I'd be like that's not that
interesting of a question but if I asked
what's what's your favorite beetle first
and then I could say John Green that
would be funny people would like that
and I so I think there's nothing wrong
with making up the occasional question
Jessica and in fact I think that it will
lead to people asking you more
interesting questions over time because
that said I suspect that Jessica because
she's at a college newspaper and has
certain obligations as a reporter she's
probably not allowed to fabricate facts
so here's what I would do Jessica to get
around the issue of journalistic ethics
and this is probably deeply immoral but
you have to remember that Hank and I
will do whatever we need to do to get a
laugh I I would just say to my friend
hey I noticed that you have this problem
can you write me about this problem and
I would just talk to people in your real
life and ask them to submit questions
that are of interest to you and then
start from there and then went once you
get a following the questions will come
in on their own and they'll be
fascinating like questions about what to
do about baby hamsters yeah or how to
listen more questions for your advice
column at your newspaper or also this
next one from Veronica this next
question comes from Veronica who asks
dear Hank and John I am having an
identity crisis I'm a 25 year old
Canadian named Veronica I have been
receiving emails for the past year from
a British person named Veronica living
across the pond living her best life
every time I receive one of these emails
I kindly reply back that they've got the
wrong Veronica but lately her life has
gotten very interesting and I can't help
but like read into her life things I
know so far she's recently interviewed
for a teaching position at a primary
school she nailed that interview and got
the job I know this because the head of
the department sends me her lesson plans
three she dressed up for Halloween as
sexy mrs. Claus I got the order
confirmation for she owns a yacht and
frequents the Yarmouth Harbor Yacht Club
soon she'll be doing a rally to burn
bridge Harbor plot twist that is a huge
plot twist it's a primary school teacher
and then I'm on one I'm on one plot
twist with sexy mrs. Claus and
apparently British Veronica doesn't know
her own email address to which to send
this email confirmation is a big
surprise for me and then BOOM she also
owns a yacht yeah I got to learn more
about the Yarmouth harbor or Yacht Club
right I mean do we know
well what is a yacht really are they're
little yachts can you have like a
reasonable yacht I just feel like well
there's a White River Yacht Club here in
Indianapolis I don't know it's exactly
the same thing but the White River Yacht
Club
almost everyone owns some kind of small
pontoon boat but I have heard that if
you are a member of the White River
Yacht Club they have reciprocity with
like every other actual Yacht Club in
the world and so you can go to the
Bermuda or whatever and you can go to
the fanciest Yacht Club's because you're
a member of the White River Yacht Club I
however am NOT a member of the White
River Yacht Club
my part of the river is completely non
navigable and therefore inaccessible to
people in their pontoon boats I gotta
say John it appears that there are a lot
of yacht clubs in England I guess so
this the the the Yarmouth Harbor Yacht
Club is on the Isle of Wight
interestingly and but there but it's
surrounded by other yacht clubs so
apparently I don't know if this person
lives on the Isle of Wight if British
Veronica lives on the Isle of Wight
that's very cool that we're easily Isle
of Wight is it in the North of the South
they don't have it assigned in the
Football League about them oh it's like
part of France no no no no no no no he
said starting an international problem
definitely not part of France it is now
it's a crisis people are calling it the
next great thing in international
relations France has just claimed the
Isle of Wight Veronica's got problems
now you're lucky you're living in Canada
Canadian Veronica to be olive white with
their cheese and their wine my big
question is how is it that this Veronica
apparently doesn't know her own email
address I mean yeah like the thing is
Kathryn has this problem too because she
has an email address that is an initial
and then a last name yes and and anybody
who has that email address is just gonna
get it they're gonna get it from a bunch
of different folks who are like yeah
that's me I'm pretty sure that's me
yeah I've also been through this where I
end up with an email address that's one
letter or two letters different from
someone else's and you become a
of weird neighbor of them knowing a lot
about their life and yet still not
participating in it I would try to track
down this British Veronica and I would
try to become her friend I mean she
seems cool and she has not we didn't
finish the question at the end of the
question Veronica asks if it's okay for
her to just take over other Veronica's
life no it does seem like becoming
friends would be a better option
especially if you could be like hey so I
heard that you're headed you're doing
that rally to burn bridge Harbor I was
wondering if I could just like bring a
couple Mike's Hard Lemonade sand do that
[Laughter]
the Hank green dream sweat it drinking
drinking to Mike's Hard Lemonade scald
becoming Hank drunk doesn't take much I
mean like what I can tell you John is
that the way that the Isle of Wight
works appears to be that Newport is just
the geographic center and it is where
all of the people are but if you want to
go from Yarmouth to the - to what
whatever that burn bridge Harbor you
very much have to go around the whole
island so I don't know which way you go
I don't know if you go around the top of
there on the bottom but it's pretty much
the complete opposite side so that's
quite a trip I bet you could get through
a couple Mike's hard lemonade's on that
trip it's gonna be a wonderful rally you
should definitely look up Veronica
Veronica and you guys should become
friends but don't take over her life
that's not cool no it's weird that you
even thought about that
yeah I don't think it's that weird but
it's not appropriate you've got her he
got a squelch that desire speaking of
which our next question comes from IU
she who's the speaking of which by the
way is completely irrelevant it's just
the fear I like to say desire I'm gonna
squelch I you she's desire not to have
an apocalypse yeah from space yes okay
ask the question some people are less
confused its tortured Dear John and Hank
in my history class we watched CNN 10
daily because my
wants us to be into current events I
enjoy this bit but the recent one was
very distressing to me because it was
about how we were going to go into World
War 3 and how it will be a space war
what the hell is CNN 10 well yeah yeah I
had to look up what CNN tennis is this
like a TV show for high school students
in which it's like digital CNN I think
no boy yeah it was completely dedicated
to how we would all die if a hacking
satellite interfere with one of our good
making everything work satellites are we
are gonna die in a space war I find this
highly improbable but everyone in my
class seems to believe it great job CNN
10 and CNN is a reputable and
trustworthy corporation or something so
should I be inclined to believe it
should I be preparing for the fight of
our lives it rhymes with sushi I you she
thanks for letting us know that I yeah I
mean the thing is we might all die in a
space war well to be fair though we
wouldn't all die in a space war we would
die in a space war that affects ground
right we wouldn't be in space when we
died of the space war but there's no
exact Biasi of us Yeah right we would
die as a result of a space war yeah
that's possible I you see I don't think
it's guaranteed no yeah that's the thing
is that like these these are meant to be
illustrative of a potential thing that
may happen and so we should be prepared
to have that be a thing that does not
happen is the idea I think behind why
they terrify us so regularly oh no is
the public service they think they think
maybe that they are they are achieving I
think that they know exactly what
they're doing which is trying to
maximize audience retention and the
great thing about predicting the future
I you she and one of the great secrets
to essentially all of contemporary
linear television so far as I can tell
is that if all you do is speculate and
predict the future no one ever comes
back to say
hey wait you've been wrong about
everything because you're not talking
about what is happening or what happened
you're talking about what may have
happened and what might happen and the
magic of those verbs is that they allow
you to never technically ever be wrong
yeah yeah and but I don't think that
it's I don't think it's bad to say like
hey look what if what if something took
argh all of our goods satellites and
messed them up how how would that go no
I think it's important right it's
important it's important to think about
problems that we might have but it's
important to think about them so that we
can try to prevent them rather than
thinking about them so that we can just
feel kind of vaguely afraid and you know
having this like creeping sense of dread
that accompanies us through every minute
of our day especially when we are young
and completely powerless in the face of
space rules I just don't know if it's
that productive yeah I agree with you
John I don't think it's gonna be space
war but you know I could be wrong it
might be there is there's a a you know
sort of the the like things that humans
might do that will end humans and ever
since we've had nuclear weapons of
course we'd have kind of had the ability
to to really mess up earth pretty dang
good at least for us and and there's
this one like nanotechnology this idea
that we could create like a nanite that
would just multiply and turn everything
on earth into itself and then I recently
read about some scientists who
accidentally made a flu virus that was
the kind of thing that would kill 70% of
people if it got out of their laboratory
and so they just destroyed it and didn't
know much their research because that
was like oh nope that's real bad we
shouldn't and and like the way that they
made it is not technically complicated
it's and I'm like no I bet wouldn't have
to like go super deep into
nanotechnology to get sort of a crazy
look like global level pandemic on you
apparently it's just flu and like a flu
virus
like eight genes John it's not
complicated
right it's a very simple thing and it's
terrifying it's so scary
that scares me like that is to me about
as that is my space war fear at the
moment right I usually since we don't
think that you should be terrified at
morning noon and night about space war
we're gonna tell you what you should be
really scared of a genetically
engineered flu virus that is extremely
easy to make and that anybody could make
in their laboratory and that someone
eventually will make and it will destroy
70% of humans great Hank what's next cut
that out but the good news the good news
is you know we should keep it in the
good news is that you have a 30% chance
of surviving this catastrophic flu and
believe you me the world that emerges
from it will be great
lots of stability all of our political
institutions which can just barely
survive our prosperity will be
completely intact don't worry and
everything will be great people will be
playing golf on manicured lawns and it
won't at all be like a post-apocalyptic
hellscape next question comes from Ian
who asks dear Hank and John recently as
I grocery shop I found myself having
intrusive thoughts along the lines of
what if I just take that bread from
somebody else's shopping cart I don't
know I'm not gonna do this but it's
gotten me thinking about who has a
legitimate claim to the contents of a
shopping cart the shopper hasn't paid
for them yet so legally the store still
owns them so should I legally be allowed
to take something from someone else's
shopping cart but if the store see no no
I mean but legally though our shopping
carts like embassies technically the
territory of the store but the shopper
has sovereignty over them yes that's
exactly the knowledge EE you've answered
your own question that is a brilliant
analogy a shopping cart is a travelling
and business like the Embassy of the of
the ownership
Hank and I'd like it still on the
sovereign still sovereignly owned by
Safeway but right right right under my
control
this this bread belongs to Safeway but
it is currently being administered by
Hank and Hank has reserved the right to
purchase this bread from the Safeway and
that sacred contract is being expressed
by the fact that it is inside of Hanks
yeah and let's all just enjoy the fact
that we can go to a grocery store and
get food because believe me understand
the people are destroyed by Hanks flu
virus we're all gonna be gardening my my
little woodchip garden is gonna be all
that stands between whatever surviving
descendants I have and complete
destruction Hank I can't get over this
I'm sorry but if I could just ask you to
turn are we still gonna like make a
podcast like what is this future going
to look like are there gonna even be
podcast well that's the thing we'll hold
on to some technology podcasts might
actually be more stable than like food
systems which is a problem yeah so what
I want to say to dial back the fear
factor a little bit is that this is
something that's known by people who
study these things and part of the
reason they study them is so that like
we can anticipate changes flu viruses
might make naturally because eventually
these things might even happen naturally
without somebody with you know malicious
intent and so that we can create
vaccines for those things so that we can
treat them so that we can yeah all that
good stuff so there that the reason that
scientists are working on this is so
that it isn't someday a problem and
hopefully that will be a thing and also
they're doing it intelligently enough
that they realized when once they did it
that they should undo it yeah they did I
don't know that I trust every group of
people who stumble upon a discovery to
be equally it it just worries me it's a
little it just freaks me out a little
bit but I'm going to
assume that everything's going to be
fine because I've been alive for 40
years and everything as well it hasn't
really it's been a really good for
decades for humans and I believe that
the next four decades can be even better
and I know that I talked about how I was
completely abandoning optimism for
pessimism and that I still believed that
this was the best year yet but I also
believed that it would be the best year
ever
but I think I'm back to optimism I
believe we are good at solving problems
and we will find a way to solve them
which reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by the people who chose
not to share that flu with the world the
people who chose not to share that fluid
with the world saving actual billions of
lives this podcast is also brought to
you by the Yarmuth Harbor Yacht Club of
Wight servin up yachts and Mike's Hard
Lemonade stew American and British
veronica's also Canadian she was
Canadian sorry Canadian vodkas of course
brought to you as always by second you
ways sacagawea's just on the cusp of
happening since their release and
additionally this podcast is brought to
you by the space war the space war it's
coming for you but not before you start
your excellent new website with
Squarespace we got a real sponsor today
yeah Squarespace you know how I use
Squarespace for hankering calm and also
every time I need to update it because
some new thing is coming out from my
book an absolutely remarkable thing
available for pre-order now coming out
September 25th I could just go in there
and be like dude dude dude fixed done I
don't have to think about it I don't
have to FTP anything I don't have to be
all fancy about it and even sometimes I
can say hey Dad can you do this for me
and he can my dad can I'm not at a
computer right now and I need to fix it
right now and dad will fix it
the Squarespace really is amazing for
those of us who made websites before
Squarespace existed we know how amazing
because they have beautiful templates
that you can use it's very intuitive it
really really works you can showcase
your work you can blog you
sell products and services right on
Squarespace without ever having to go
off of it it is a really wonderful
platform I use it for my website John
Green Comm Hank uses it for just kidding
I don't have John Green Comm it's owned
by a realtor in Southern Mississippi and
has been since the early 90s but Hank
gets to use it for his website Hank
green comm and we both really love
working with it so please check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you are ready to launch you can use
the offer code dear Hank or I would
personally prefer that you use the offer
code dear John and you can save 10% off
of your first purchase of a website or
domain again that's can save 10% by
using the offer code dear Hank or Dear
John but do use Dear John or dear Hank
as first baek's takes care of all of
your security so you don't have to worry
about that it has built-in search engine
optimization you don't have to patch
things don't have to upgrade things and
you have 24/7 award-winning customer
support for when you get confused or
something
seems weird so yeah Squarespace it makes
it makes it work man it makes it work
that way that's not that's not their
actual tagline it's a good Squarespace
it makes things work it's very submit
that to Squarespace Squarespace
makes it work I had to say Hank before
we move on how much I like the cover of
your book an absolutely remarkable thing
which is available for pre-order now I
really really cool book cover I hope
that you're happy with it it's pretty
rare to get a book cover on a first
novel that is so good yeah I like it so
so much I have been thinking obviously a
lot of book covers lately and and
there's a lot of different directions
you can go and you start from this sort
of infinite number of possibilities and
I think we ended up in a really great
place I'm looking at it right now John I
am I've never been more obsessed with a
piece of design in my life I unhealthy
relationship with how much I like this
book cover the weird thing is that you
do as the author have to live with it so
much and for so long
in a way that nobody else has to write
because it's gonna be you're gonna show
it to your kids and hopefully one day
you'll show it to your grandkids and you
know our great-great uncle wrote a novel
and there are hardly any copies in
circulation but you and I have seen the
cover of it and so it's something that
that survives in a weird way and as the
author I mean I know that like the cover
of Looking for Alaska I never could have
imagined how much time I was going to
spend looking at that cover and thinking
about it over the next 15 years
but I'm very grateful that I ended up
with a cover of a book that I like it
actually
these days all of my book covers are
ones that I like so it that is a real
blessing and a rare one so I'm glad that
you like it I really like it I'm really
happy for you and also John not me John
with no age donated to the project for
awesome to give us to say this message
which we are happy to say because we are
really interested in the work that this
organization is doing so this is John's
message that he donated the project for
awesome to get us to say this message is
a plug for an organization I'm a really
big fan of give well a nonprofit
dedicated to finding outstanding giving
opportunities through in-depth analysis
thousands of hours of research have gone
into funding their top-rated charities
these charities are evidence-based
thoroughly vetted and underfunded if you
want to know more check out give
well.org
and check out their research so again
that's give well.org thank you John for
donating the p4a and for taking the
opportunity to try to decrease worldsuck
totally dope that was very cool of you
John I thought that was gonna be about
me but it wasn't it was about a
different John I've always just want to
say that about me but it's never
happened let's answer some more
questions here you're all so dope uh-huh
is that what you wanted to hear this
question comes from will who asks dear
Hank and John my girlfriend and I just
moved in together for the first time and
I am ecstatic however I do have a slight
qualms she has these lamps and tables
that are bright periwinkle how do i
express to her that they don't exactly
go with the rest of the decor and that I
would rather go with simple white her
mom painted them and I don't want to
offend my possible future mother-in-law
her mom can be a bit standoffish at
times any
Buse advice would be greatly appreciated
wait where there's a way there's a will
um will yeah well we I think John and I
have the same piece of advice for you
you're gonna learn to love those bright
periwinkle tables and lamps because
people who you care about who are
important to you and your life worked
hard to make them and made conscious
careful thoughtful choices about that
color and you're gonna incorporate it
into your life
yep that's it man I mean there another
is there more to say about this or if
they're just another way to say it yeah
I yeah but even aesthetically just paint
the other stuff white right and so the
periwinkle becomes the pop of color in
that room just have have your bed be
neutral or your carpet be neutral there
I think I'm not an expert in this field
but I think it is a bad plan to repaint
that lamp yeah yeah and I think I think
it's a weird conversation to have to
some extent like you may imagine this as
like emotional labor on your part like a
thing that you are doing and that it
means that you're like your living
experience isn't the exact way that you
would imagine it but that it is it is a
it is a part of being a part of this new
thing that you are creating with your s
oh I took me a second to figure out what
an Esso was but now I realize it's a
significant other I was just gonna
highlight that for people who might have
struggled with it the way I was
struggling with it we have something in
our house that is somewhat similar to
this there's a painting in our house
that there's stuff that we you once you
once you form a partnership I think you
start to pick out stuff together right
but then there's some stuff that you
bring into the relationship that you
bring into the first apartment that
you know like you picked out on your own
it might not suit the other person's
interests and that you mate you may not
have picked together and here's what I
tell myself when I see this one painting
someone I love loves this painting
that's what I think and I find it very
helpful and it makes me like the
painting and I think eventually you're
gonna like those periwinkle lamps
actually to me they sound nice I think
we'll you might be wrong on every level
I think these pearl earring programs
might be a winner but even if they're
wrong every level I face what you ride
in for the pod for I've just tried I'm
trying to level with you will I think I
think you're headed down the wrong path
hopefully we've saved you in time all
right Hank this next question comes from
Meghan who writes do you John and Hank I
must know where does the phrase the
world is your oyster come from and how
does it make any sense if the world is
your oyster does this mean the purpose
of life is to discover your pearl yeah
what if your oyster doesn't have a pearl
and if a pearl is actually just made up
of irritants and calcium isn't it more
like a kidney stone are you allergic to
shellfish dubious answers are welcome as
my friends and I have been plagued by
this question for a long long time
although apparently not long enough to
Google it was that part of the question
did you add that in no I added that so I
don't want you are you gonna tell me the
actual answer to this question I am
gonna tell you the actual answer but go
ahead and speculate the first I'm just
gonna say that like what I know about
oysters is that they're ugly and and
like gross and and like scraggly on the
outside and then inside the inside of
the shells are nice but then there's
like this goopy soupy thing that is the
the animal itself and so I don't even
really know where the oyster begins and
where the shell begins I don't like I'm
not entirely sure like the world is my
oyster meaning you can open it up and
see what's in there I guess but in
general I just feel like no no first of
all waste is very small very simple and
goopy gross I don't want my world to be
any of those things and indeed the way
that it is currently used makes no sense
especially when you find out
the phrase came from which is from
William Shakespeare's The Merry Wives of
Windsor and in this scene Falstaff says
I will not to pistol I will not lend you
any money I will not lend me a penny and
then pistol replies why then the world's
my oyster which I with sword will open
and then Falstaff says not a penny
so what pistol is saying is OK
you won't lend me any money I get that I
know how to get money out of you by
using a sword ie I am going to rob you I
am going to force your pocketbook open
with my sword the way that I would force
an oyster open with my sword so it has
essentially no relationship to the idea
that the world is your oyster because I
mean I guess maybe the world is your
oyster if you have if you already have
money I think it is your oyster if you
have a soul waster is saying there
waiting for you to open it up right but
in the scene what's happening is that
pistol is throwing false EFT with theft
well it is aren't we all stealing every
time we eat an oyster because it was
that was the property of the oyster yes
a body of the oyster I find it to have
been essentially like a mistranslated
phrase that it must be the way that it
the way yes something something maybe
it's iambic or something there's must be
something about the phrase itself that
feels true to us even though makes the
more you investigated the less true it
becomes which is maybe also reflective
of something about how we actually think
that we have a lot of control and
sovereignty over our lives and what
happens to them but in fact the world in
truth is almost never our oyster right
the world is your oyster in the sense
that maleic some oyster somewhere far
away that you can't control and that you
have yield every little find and it may
or may not have pearls in it it's just
like every person has an oyster
and it only exists for a limited amount
of time and you like no one ever
actually gets it there you go thanks for
listening to dear Hank and John next
question I still have one more question
before we get to the news from Mars and
hey if so go John
it comes from Erin who asks dear Hank
and John I've recently been invited to
join a small weekly critique group which
is fantastic but one of the members
looks almost exactly like Ryan Gosling
the resemblance is eerie I can't look at
him in the eye it's like looking into
the Sun how do I have to spit and now I
have to spend one evening a week in his
presence this guy has a reputation for
being professional and kind and honest
he's a good contact to have I can't risk
weirding him out and yet I'm sure that
I'll either say something idiotic or
else avoid interaction to the point of
unfriendliness I could do with some
dubious advice right about now trial and
arin so my best friend Chris looks a lot
like Vince Vaughn I realized this isn't
the exact same problem Erin then he
looks more like Vince Vaughn different
problem in some ways he looks more like
Vince Vaughn than contemporary Vince
Vaughn does like Chris looks more like
Vince Vaughn in wedding crashers than
Vince Vaughn looks like Vince Vaughn and
wedding crashers and yeah the way that I
dealt with this Erin is by the first
time I hung out with Chris I had a few
drinks and then I looked over at him and
I said you know you look exactly like
Vince Vaughn and you also talk like
Vince Vaughn and it almost seems like
kind of a performance and he paused and
he said I usually get Vincent D'Onofrio
and then that then it was over a
different Vince who's Vincent and I was
in like Law & Order criminal intent I
think he I think he had a long and
storied career before that but I most
recently saw him in law and order
criminal intent ya know that guy looks
like Chris yeah essentially every
Hollywood actor named Vince looks like
Chris Vincent D'Onofrio the guy who
plays the Edgar and men in black
possibly and then the alien puts on the
anger I feel like we're stumbling into
this week's this week in Ryan so let's
not get ahead of ourselves
yeah I mean I have you had ever had the
problem where you are sort of like
someone is so like I don't know
beautiful to look at that it interferes
with your ability to have a normal human
relationship always that the question I
thought that it was so distracting I
thought it was just so distracting to
have somebody who looked like a
celebrity I think I misinterpreted the
question well I think it's a little bit
of oh so one it's this person looks like
Ryan Gosling second have you seen Ryan
Gosling yeah no he's he's got a very
symmetrical face yeah I don't know I
don't know how to solve that second
problem I only know how to solve the
problem of making making it normal to
announce to someone that they look like
a celebrity
I suppose if that celebrity is Ryan
Gosling it is a form of it is weird to
say you look like Ryan Gosling right
because Ryan Gosling is widely perceived
to be the definition of hot yes so maybe
you just say hey has anybody ever told
you you look like Ryan Reynolds no you
gotta go you gotta go with that hey is
anyone ever told you you look like adult
Macaulay Culkin here's the thing that
you should do actually Aaron is you
should just wait because eventually this
person will start to look like
themselves it's totally true it'll it is
that is my advice yes in my experience
people start to become themselves and
they start to become people and and what
they look like fades a lot there you go
that's our advice Hank we've got to get
to the all-important news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon but first I just want to
say a quick thank you to everybody who
supports dear Hank and John on patreon
you can get our weekly terrible podcast
this week in Ryan's where we've
discussed I believe both Ryan Gosling
and Ryan Reynolds but you can go to
patreon.com/scishow Hank and John and
get you don't have to actually sign up
to see the content but you can if you
want donate and then the money goes to
complexly to support scishow and crash
course and the art assignment and the
other shows that we make at complexly so
thank you to everybody who supports us
on patreon you can listen to this week
in Ryan's after you listen to this
podcast over at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John but Hank what is the news
from Mars this way
news from Mars this week John the Mars
Curiosity rover as we have discussed
previously has a drill on it that broke
so it's it's the only way we have to get
samples from the interior of rocks on
Mars and that's a big deal because the
exterior of rocks on Mars has chemistry
that happens to it and is thus going to
be different from the interior so you
can drill in there and then scoop a
little bit of the sample up and then
take it over to the onboard science
laboratories on the Curiosity rover but
more than a year ago that drill broke
one of the wheel motors that keeps it in
place broke and we've been
troubleshooting it to try and get it to
collect dust to figure out how to drill
into rocks ever since then and we've got
a like a earthbound one that we had been
testing to get it to figure out how to
do this and it figured out how to do it
and then we sent all that software up
with the Curiosity rover and just this
week it made its first drill on the
surface of Mars and over a year a
successful test drill the next step is
to try and figure out how to actually
get that dust that it drilled up from
the rock to the onboard laboratories and
that also that all the systems that part
of what broke is the systems that would
get that there so what they're thinking
about doing is actually using the drill
bit moving the drill bit over to the the
laboratory is basically tapping the
drill bit to get the dust to just fall
off of it and that works with the the
one here on earth but obviously you know
their atmosphere and gravity are
different on earth so hopefully it will
work on Mars too but we don't know but
it has done its first sample test drill
since it broke and it worked and
everybody's very excited and I basically
I could watch a documentary film on the
year of work that these engineers have
done to get that drill back up and
running you should have made that
documentary that sounds properly
interesting especially if you have the
right soundtrack I find that in general
mostly need a good score so speaking of
scoring mmm we haven't been AFC
Wimbledon America's
favorite third-tier English soccer team
lost their most recent game now now well
actually their most recent game was
cancelled because of weather I don't
know if you heard about this but there
was this huge storm in England they
called it the beast from the east
because it originated in Russia and it
was very cold there and there was a
frozen pitch so they couldn't play so
there's that there are now 11 games
remaining in the league one season and
AFC Wimbledon is clinging clinging by
one point to safety right now in in 19th
place 21st through 24th go down AFC
Wimbledon is just barely safe in 19th
place on 38 points after 35 games there
are 11 games left to ensure safety
wimbledon are gonna need 52 points so
that's 14 points from their remaining 11
games that's a lot huh it's very I don't
want to minimize how nerve-racking it is
I want to be hopeful and optimistic but
it is very scary and this you know
obviously the stakes are extremely high
it's hard to get up to Ligue 1 it took a
Herculean effort and a little bit of
luck for Wimbledon to get up to Ligue 1
and it would be pretty devastating to
get relegated so right now one point
clear and also the franchise currently
flying it's trade in Milton Keynes is in
the relegation zone 32 points after 35
games so there is still the distinct
possibility that those two clubs are
going to be vying for safety at the end
of the season which is terrifying and
yes boy hmm I'm worried mm-hmm so is the
the game you lost was to the team that
was gonna beat you probably no matter
what right that is correct and they did
beat us no matter what they beat us
three nil and it was not close but next
we play Oxford United and then a huge
game against we have actually three of
our remaining games are against teams
currently in the relegation zone
so those games are obviously all massive
so it hey yeaaah we'll see ya okay well
so that yeah but that yeah that's really
interesting so that's that's coming up
in the next weeks or the next week know
the game yeah
March 17th st. Patrick's Day is is a
good game that's a you don't want to you
don't want to talk about must-win games
because that only puts pressure on the
team I don't want to put pressure on the
team but I don't think they listen to
this so I'll tell you the truth it's a
must-win game all right well we're all
rootin for you John thanks Hank what did
we learn today well we learned that the
inside of your shopping cart is has
diplomatic immunity from the rest of the
shoppers we learned that the Yarmouth
Harbor Yacht Club is your number one
Yarmouth Yacht Club actually probably
not I think it I think it's the number
one Yarmouth Yacht Club I think there's
just the one it's certainly times five
its top five that baby hamsters we don't
know what to do with them and I don't
know why you're asking us and we learned
that space Wars might kill us but not if
the flu does first John thanks for
making a podcast with me always a
pleasure I don't remember how we end the
podcast but usually you read the credits
oh this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and Sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno this music that you're
hearing now and it's beginning the
podcast and during this weekend Ryan's
is all by the great gunnarolla and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]